نعم
[Silence]
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولا تجا دلوا اهل الكتاب الا بالتي
هي احسن الا الذين ظلموا
منهم وقولوا امنا بالذي انزل الينا وانزل
اليكم والهنا والهكم
واحد والهنا والهكم واحد ونحن له
مسلمون وكذلك ذلك
انزلنا اليك
الكتاب فالذين
اتيناهم الكتاب يؤمنون
به ومن
هؤلاء من يؤمن به وما يجحد باياتنا الا
الكافرون وما كنت تتلو من قبله من كتاب
ولا تخطه
بيمينك ولا تخطه بيمينك اذا لارتاب
المبطلون بل هو ايات بينات في صدور الذين
اوتوا
العلم وما يجحد
باياتنا الا
الظالمون وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ايات من
ربه قل
انما الايات عند
الله
وانما انا نذير مبين اولم يكفهم انا
انزلنا عليك الكتاب يتلى
عليهم ان في ذلك لرحمه وذكرى لقوم
يؤمنون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين اولم يكفهم انا انزلنا عليك الكتاب
يتلى
عليهم ان في ذلك لرحمه وذكرى
لقوم
يؤمنون قل كفى بالله بيني وبين بينكم
شهيدا يعلم ما في السماوات
والارض والذين امنوا بالباطل وكفروا بالله
اولئك هم
الخاسرون
ويستعجلونك
بالعذاب ولولا اجل مسمى
لجاءهم العذاب
لياتينهم
بغته وهم لا
يشعرون
يستعجلونك
بالعذاب وان جهنم
لمحيطه
بالكافرين يوم يغشاهم العذاب من فوقهم ومن
تحت
ارجلهم ويقول ذوقوا ما كنتم
تعملون يا عبادي الذين امنوا ان ارضي
واسعه فاياي
فاعبدون كل نفس
ذائقه
الموت ثم الينا
ترجعون والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لنبوئهم
لنبوئهم من الجنه
غرفا تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها نعم اجر
العاملين الذين
صبروا الذين صبروا وعلى ربهم يتوكلون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله আসসালামু
আলাইকুম
আলহামদুলিল্লাহ এন্ড অফ ரமான்
অnoউম firstஒ
இஸ்டங்
இஷல் at
andரக்f
served
second
personay more the bo areable so pleas
‏as you can everybody in the
family
and will be after the will be with
prayer that you can join but there will
be when we come back will
be pray and will be following that will
be with pray again so want to ‏nobody
confused about that praying
twi in this but not everybody be the who
pray the first time don't need to pray
for the second time so do what you can
so just
امام حسن السلام
[Silence]
அலைக்கும்
টোফিং
পিটিquate 5 minut of what going
financially donate that time is to us to
have the fundraising in a man that can
be very helpful
‏So
again be asking and are asking something
you can do your own math and say
so much per month and this is what I can
so not something are asking to be
delivered or pa away what you can do
to make arrangement for any بلانز
جزاك
الله استقيموا واعتدلوا
استووا سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وكاي من
دابه لا تحمل رزقها الله يرزقها
واياكم وهو السميع العليم ولئن سالتهم من
خلق السماوات والارض وسخر الشمس والقمر
ليقولن
الله فانا
يؤفكون الله يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء
من عباده ويقدر له ان الله بكل شيء عليم
ولئن
سالتهم من نزل من
السماء ولئن
السماء
ماء فاحيا به الارض من بعد موتها
ليقولن
الله قل الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعقلون وما هذه الحياه الدنيا الا لهو
ولعب وان الدار الاخره لهي الحيوان لو
كانوا
يعلمون فاذا ركبوا في الفلك دعوا الله
مخلصين له الدين فلما نجاهم الى البر اذا
هم
يشركون ليكفروا بما
اتيناهم
وليتمتعوا
وليتمتعوا فسوف
يعلمون اولم يعلموا ان اولم يروا انا
جعلنا حرما امنا ويتخطف
الناس ويتخطف
الناس من حولهم افبالباطل يؤمنون وبنعمه
الله
يكفرون ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب بالحق لما
جاءه اليس في جهنم مثواى
للكافرين والذين جاهدوا فينا
لنهدينهم سبلنا
وان الله لمع
المحسنين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الم
م غلبت الروم في ادنى الارض وهم من بعد
غلبهم
سيغلبون في بضع
سنين لله الامر من قبل ومن
بعد
ويومئذ يفرح
المؤمنون بنصر الله ينصر من
يشاء وهو العزيز الرحيم وعد الله لا يخلف
الله وعده ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون يعلمون
ظاهرا من الحياه الدنيا وهم عن الاخره هم
غافلون اولم يتفكروا في
انفسهم ما خلق الله
السماوات ما خلق الله السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا بالحق واجل
مسمى وان كثيرا من الناس
بلقاء ربهم
لكافرون اولم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من
قبلهم كانوا اشد منهم قوه واثاروا الارض
وعمروها واثاروا الارض
وعمروها وعمروها اكثر مما
عمروها وجا
جاءتهم رسلهم
بالبينات فما كان الله ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون ثم كان عاقبه الذين
اساءوا
السوء ان كذبوا بايات
الله وكانوا بها
يستهزئون الله يبدا يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده
ثم اليه
ترجعون ويوم تقوم الساعه يبلس
المجرمون ولم يكن لهم من
شركائهم
شفعاء وكانوا
بشركائهم
كافرين ويوم تقوم الساعه
يومئذ يتفرق
فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات فهم في
روضه
يحبرون واما الذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا
ولقاء
الاخره
فاولئك في العذاب محضرون
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فسبحان الله حين تمسون وحين تصب
حون وله الحمد في السماوات والارض وعشيا
وحين
تظهرون يخرج الحي من الميت ويخرج الميت من
الحي ويحيي الارض بعد موتها وكذلك
تخرجون ومن اياته ان خلقكم من
تراب ثم اذا انتم بشر
تنتشرون ومن اياته ان خلق لكم من
انفسكم ازواجا لتسكنوا
اليها وجعل بينكم
موده ورحمه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون ومن اياته خلق السماوات السماوات
والارض واختلاف السنتكم
والوانكم ان في ذلك لايات
للعالمين ومن اياته
منامكم
بالليل ومن اياته منامكم بالليل والنهار
وابتغاؤكم من فضله ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يسمعون ومن اياته يريكم البرق
خوفا
وطمعا وينزل من
السماء ماء فيحيي به الارض بعد
موتها ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون ومن اياته
ان تقوم
السماء والارض
بامره ثم اذا دعاكم دعوه من الارض اذا
انتم
تخرجون وله من في السماوات والارض كل له
قانتون وهو الذي يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده وهو
اهون
عليه وله المثل الاعلى في السماوات
والارض وهو العزيز الحكيم ضرب لكم مثلا من
انفسكم هل لكم مما ملكت
ايمانكم هل لكم مما ملكت ايمانكم من
شركاء فيما رزقناكم
فيما
رزقناكم فانتم فيه
سواء تخافونهم
كخيفكم
انفسكم كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم
يعقلون بل اتبع الذين ظلموا
اهواءهم بغير
علم فمن يهدي من اضل من اضل ضل الله وما
لهم من
ناصرين فاقم وجهك للدين
حنيفا فطره الله التي فطر الناس عليها لا
تبديل لخلق
الله ذلك الدين القيم ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون منيبين اليه واتقوه واقيموا الصلاه
ولا تكونوا من
المشركين من الذين فرقوا دينهم وكانوا
شيعا كل
حزب بما لديهم فرحون
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله اكبر سبحانك
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين واذا مس الناس ضر دعوا ربهم منيبين
اليه ثم
اذاقهم منه رحمه اذا فريق منهم بربهم
يشركون ليكفروا بما اتيناهم فتمتعوا فسوف
تعلمون ام انزلنا عليهم سلطانا فهو يتكلم
بما كانوا به
يشركون واذا اذقنا الناس رحمه فرحوا بها
وان تصبهم سيئه بما قدمت ايديهم اذا هم
يقنطون اولم يروا ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء ويقدر
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون فات ذا القربى حقه والمسكين وابن
السبيل ذلك خير للذين يريدون وجه الله
واولئك هم
المفلحون وما اتيتم من ربا ليربو في اموال
الناس فلا لا يربو عند
الله وما اتيتم من زكاه تريدون وجه الله
فاولئك هم
المضعفون فاولئك هم
المضعفون الله الذي خلقكم ثم
رزقكم ثم يميتكم ثم
يحييكم هل من شرك
ركائكم من يفعل من ذلكم من
شيء سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون ظهر الفساد في البر والبحر بما
كسبت ايدي الناس
ليذيقهم بعض الذي عملوا لعلهم
يرجعون قل سيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين من قبل كان اكثرهم
مشركين فاقم وجهك للدين القيم من قبل ان
ياتي يوم لا مرد له من الله
يومئذ
يصدعون من كفر فعليه كفره ومن عمل صالحا
فلانفسهم يمهد
ليجزي الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات من
فضله
انه لا يحب
الكافرين ومن اياته ان يرسل الرياح مبشرات
وليذيقكم
وليذيقكم من رحمته ولتجري الفلك بامره
ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعل لعلكم تشكرون ولقد
ارسلنا من قبلك رسلا الى قومهم
فجاؤوهم
بالبينات فانتقمنا من الذين اجرموا وكان
حقا
علينا وكان حقا علينا نصر
المؤمنين الله الذي يرسل الرياح فتثير
سحابا
فتثير سحابا فيبسطه في
السماء كيف
يشاء ويجعله
كسفا فترى الودق يخرج من
خلاله فاذا اصاب به من يشاء من عباده اذا
هم
يستبشرون وان كانوا من قبل ان ينزل عليهم
من قبله
لمبلسين فانظر الى اثار رحمه الله كيف
يحيي الارض بعد
موتها ان في ذلك ان ذلك لمحيي الموتى وهو
على كل شيء قدير ولئن ارسلنا ريحا فراوه
مصفرا لظلوا من بعده
يكفرون
فانك لا تسمع الموتى ولا تسمع الصم
الدعاء ولا تسمعوا
الصم
الدعاء اذا ولوا
مدبرين وما انت بهادي العمي عن
ضلالتهم ان تسمع الا من يؤمن
باياتنا
فهم مسلمون
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
الله اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الله الذي خلقكم من ضعف ثم جعل من
بعد ضعف قوه ثم جعل من بعد قوه ضعفا وشيبا
يخلق ما يشاء وهو العليم القدير ويوم تقوم
الساعه يقسم المجرمون ما لبثوا غير ساعه
كذلك كانوا
يؤفكون وقال الذين اوتوا العلم والايمان
لقد لبثتم في كتاب الله الى يوم البعث
فهذا يوم البعث
ولكنكم كنتم لا
تعلمون فيومئذ لا
ينفع الذين ظلموا معذرتهم ولا هم
يستعتبون ولقد
ضربنا ولقد ضربنا للناس في هذا القران من
كل مثل ولئن جئتهم بايه ليقولن الذين
كفروا
ليقولن الذين كفروا ان انتم الا
مبطلون كذلك يطبع الله على قلوب الذين لا
يعلمون فاصبر
ان وعد الله حق ولا
يستخفنك الذين لا يوقنون
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الم
م تلك ايات الكتاب الحكيم هدى ورحمه
للمحسنين الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون
الزكاه وهم بالاخر خره هم يوقنون اولئك
على هدى من ربهم واولئك هم
المفلحون ومن الناس من يشتري لهو الحديث
ليضل عن سبيل الله بغير علم ليضل عن سبيل
الله بغير علم
ويتخذها
هزوا
اولئك لهم عذاب
مهين واذا تتلى عليه اياتنا ولا مستكبرا
كان لم يسمعها كان في اذنيه وقرا فبشره
بعذاب اليم ان الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات لهم
جنات النعيم خالدين
فيها وعد الله حقا
وهو العزيز الحكيم خلق السماوات بغير عمد
ترونها والقى في الارض رواسي ان تميد
بكم وبث فيها من كل
دابه وانزلنا من
السماء
ماء فانبتنا
فيها
فانبتنا فيها من كل زوج كريم هذا خلق الله
فاروني ماذا خلق الذين من
دونه بل الظالمون في ضلال مبين ولقد
اتينا ولقد اتينا لقمان الحكمان اشكر لله
من يشكر فانما يشكر لنفسه ومن كفر فان
الله غني
حميد واذ قال واذ قال لقمان واذ قال لقمان
لابنه وهو يعظه يا بني لا تشرك
بالله
ان الشرك لظلم عظيم ووصينا انسان بوالديه
حملته امه وهنا على
وهن وفصاله في
عامين ان اشكر لي ولوالديك الي المصير وان
جاهداك على ان تشرك بي ما ليس لك به علم
فلا
تطعهما وصاحبهما في الدنيا
معروفا واتبع سبيل من اناب الي
ثم الي
مرجعكم
فانبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون يا بني انها ان تك مثقال حبه من
خردل فتكن في صخره فتكن في صخره او في
السماوات او في ارض يات بها
الله ان الله لطيف خبير يا بني اقم الصلاه
وامر بالمعروف وانهى عن المنكر واصبر على
ما اصابك ان في ذلك ان ذلك من عزم
الامور ولا تصعر خدك للناس ولا تمش في
الارض مرحا ان الله لا يحب كل مختار فخور
واقصد في مشيك واغض من صوتك ان انكر
الاصوات لصوت
الحمير الم تروا ان الله سخر لكم ما في
السماوات وما في
الارض واسبغ عليكم نعمه
ظاهره
وباطنه ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير
علم ولا هدى ولا كتاب منير واذا قيل لهم
اتبعوا ما انزل الله قالوا قالوا بل نتبع
ما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا اولو او كان الشيطان يدعوهم الى
عذاب السعير
الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
primمضان صلى الله عليه
عائشه رضي الله عن عائشه رضي الله
عنها رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عباده
[Silence]
صلاه
رمضان ليله
القدر الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏allerانه
وتعالى ليله القدر
[Silence]
ليله
القدر ليله القدر
[Silence]
‏diffic
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران الله سبحانه وتعالى انا انزلناه في
ليله مباركه انا كنا منذرين فيها يفرق كل
امر حكيم
الله سبحانه
وتعالى فيها يفرق كل امر
حكيم ليله القدر
[Silence]
اللوح
المحفوظ الله سبحانه وتعالى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى اللوح
المحفوظ ليله
القدر المحفوظ عبد الله بن عباس رضي الله
عنه
سد
[Silence]
امان ليله القدر
قران ليله
القدر رسول الله سبحانه وتعالى سينزل قران
انا انزلناه في ليله
القدر وما ادراكما ليله القدر ليله القدر
خير من الف شهر تنزل الملائكه والروح فيها
باذن ربهم من كل امر سلام هي حتى مطلع
الفجر الله سبحانه
وتالى
years 83
‏my
time الله سبحانه وتعالى ليله القدر خير
من الف شهر تنزل الملائكه والروح فيها
باذن ربهم من كل
امر عليه السلام
الله جبريل عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتله
القدر الله سبحانه
وتعالى
att الله سبحانه وتعالى
تنزل الملائكه والروح فيها باذن ربهم من
كل امر سلام هي حتى مطلع
الفجرين الله سبحانه وتالى
ليله القدر عبد الله بن
عباس الله سبحانه
وتعالى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
رمضان
عبادات الله ذكر
ر اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
جزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
استووا
‏Mواد الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومن يسلم وجهه الى الله وهو محسن فقد
استمسك بالعروه الوثقى
والى الله عاقبه الامور ومن كفر فلا يحزنك
كفره الينا مرجعهم فننبئهم بما عملوا ان
الله عليم بذات
الصدور نمتعهم قليلا ثم نضطرهم الى عذاب
غليظ ولئن
سالتهم من خلق السماوات السماوات والارض
ليقولن الله قل الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون لله ما في السماوات والارض ان الله
هو الغني
الحميد ولو ان ما في الارض من شجره اقلام
والبحر يمده من بعده سبعه ابحر ما نفدت
كلمات
الله ان الله عزيز
حكيم ما خلقكم ولا بعثكم الا كنفس واحده
ان الله سميع
بصير الم تر ان الله يولج الليل في النهار
ويولج النهار في الليل وسخر الشمس
والقمر وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري الى اجل
مسمى وان الله بما تعملون
خبير ذلك بان الله هو الحق وانما يدعون من
دونه
الباطل وان الله هو العلي
الكبير الم تر ان الفلك تجري في البحر
بنعمه الله ليريد كم من
اياته ان في ذلك لايات لكل صبار
شكور واذا
غشيهم موج كالظلل دعوا الله مخلصين له
الدين فلما نجاهم الى البر فمنهم
مقتصد وما يجحد باياتنا الا كل ختار كفور
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم واخشوا
يوما واخشوا يوما لا يجزي والد عن ولده
ولا مولود هو جاز عن والده شيئا ان وعد
الله حق فلا
تغرنكم الحياه الدنيا ولا يغرنكم
لله
الغرور ان الله عنده علم الساعه وينزل
الغيث ويعلم ما في
الارحام وما تدري نفس ماذا تكسب غدا وما
تدري نفس باي ارض
تموت ان الله عليم
خبير بسم الله الرحم الرحمن
الرحيم الم
م تنزيل الكتاب لا ريب فيه من رب
العالمين ام يقولون
افتراه بل هو الحق من ربك لتنذر قوما ما
اتاهم من نذير من قبلك لعلهم
يهتدون الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض وما بينهما في سته ايام ثم استوى
على
العرش ما لكم من دونه من ولي ولا شفيع
افلا
تتذكرون يدبر الامر من السماء الى الارض
ثم يعرج اليه في يوم كان مقداره 1000 سنه
مما تعدون
ذلك عالم الغيب والشهاده العزيز
الرحيم الذي احسن كل شيء خلقه وبدا خلق
الانسان من
طين ثم جعل نسله من سلاله من ماء
مهين ثم سواه ونفخ فيه من روحه وجعل لكم
السمع والابصار والافئده قليلا ما
تشكرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقالوا ائذا ضللنا في الارض اانا لفي
خلق جديد بل هم
بلقاء ربهم
كافرون قل يتوفاكم ملك الموت الذي وكل بكم
ثم الى ربكم
ترجعون ولو ترى اذ المجرمون ناكسوا رؤوسهم
عند ربهم ربنا ابصرنا وسمعنا فارجعنا نعمل
صالحا انا
موقنون ولو شئنا لاتينا كل نفس هداها ولكن
حق القول مني
لاملان جهنم من الجنه والناس
اجمعين فذوقوا بما نسيتم لقاء يومكم هذا
انا
نسيناكم وذوقوا عذاب الخلد بما كنتم
تعملون
انما يؤمن باياتنا الذين اذا ذكروا بها
خروا
سجدا خروا
سجدا وسبحوا بحمد ربهم وهم لا
يستكبرون الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر تتجافى جنوبهم عن المضاجع يدعون ربهم
خوفا وطمعا ومما رزقناهم ينفقون
فلا تعلم نفس ما اخفي لهم من قره اعين
جزاء بما كانوا
يعملون افمن كان مؤمنا كمن كان فاسقا لا
يستوون اما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فلهم جنات الماوى نزلا بما كانوا يعملون
واما الذين فسقوا فماواهم
النار كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها اعيدوا
فيها وقيل لهم ذوقوا عذاب النار الذي كنتم
به
تكذبون
ولنذيقنهم من العذاب الادنى دون العذاب
الاكبر لعلهم يرجعون
ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات الله ثم اعرض عنها
انا من المجرمين
منتقمون ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه ثم
اعرض عنها انا من المجرمين
منتقمون ولقد قد اتينا موسى الكتاب فلا
تكن في مريه من
لقائه وجعلناه هدى لبني
اسرائيل وجعلنا منهم ائمه يهدون بامرنا
لما صبروا وكانوا باياتنا
يوقنون ان ربك هو يفصل بينهم يوم القيامه
فيما كانوا فيه يختلف
تلفنون اولم يهد لهم كم اهلكنا من قبلهم
من القرون يمشون في
مساكنهم افلا
يسمعون ان في ذلك لايات افلا
يسمعون اولم يروا انا نسوق
الماء الى الارض الجرز فنخرج به زرعا
فنخرج به
زرعا تاكل منه انعامهم
وانفسهم افلا
يبصرون ويقولون متى هذا الفتح ان كنتم
صادقين قل يوم الفتح لا ينفع الذين كفروا
ايمانهم ولا هم
ينظرون فاعرض عنهم وانتظر انهم هم
منتظرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها النبي اتق الله ولا تطع
الكافرين
والمنافقين ان الله كان عليما حكيما واتبع
ما يوحى اليك من ربك ان الله كان بما
تعملون خبيرا وتوكل على الله وكفى بالله
وكيلا ما جعل الله لرجل من قلبين في جوفه
وما جعل ازواجكم
اللائي تظاهرون منهن
امهاتكم وما جعل
ادعياءكم
ابناءكم ذلكم قولكم بافواهكم والله يقول
الحق وهو يهدي
السبيل ادعوهم
لابائهم هو اقسط عند
الله فان لم تعلموا اباءهم
فاخوانكم في الدين
ومواليكم فاخوانكم في الدين
ومواليكم ولا وليس عليكم جناح فيما اخطاتم
به ولكن ما تعمدت
قلوبكم وكان الله غفورا
رحيما النبي اولى بالمؤمنين من
انفسهم وازواجه امهاتهم
واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في كتاب
الله من المؤمنين
والمهاجرين الا ان تفعلوا الى
اوليائكم
معروفا كان ذلك في الكتاب
مستورا واذ اخذنا من النبيين ميثاقهم ومنك
ومن نوح وابراهيم وموسى وعيسى ابن مريم
واخذنا منهم ميثاقا
غليظا ليسال الصادقين عن صدقهم واعد
للكافرين عذابا اليما يا ايها الذين امنوا
اذكروا نعمه الله عليكم اذ جاءتكم
جنود اذ جاءتكم جنود
فارسلنا عليهم ريحا وجنودا لم تروها وكان
الله بما تعملون
بصيرا اذ
جاؤوكم من فوقكم ومن اسفل منكم واذ زاغت
الابصار وبلغت القلوب
الحناجر
وتظنون بالله
الظنونا هنالك ابتلي المؤمنون وزلزلوا
زلزالا
شديدا واذ يقول المنافقون والذين في
قلوبهم مرض ما وعدنا الله ورسوله الا
غرورا واذ قالت
طائفه منهم يا اهل يثرب لا مقام لكم
فارجعوا ويستاذن
فريق منهم النبي يقولون ان بيوتنا عوره
وما هي بعوره ان يريدون الا
فرارا ولو دخلت
عليهم من اقطارها ثم سئلوا الفتنه لاتوها
وما تنبثوا بها الا
يسيرا ولقد كانوا عاهدوا الله من قبل لا
يولون
الادبار وكان عهد الله مسؤول
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
برده
اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد كانوا عاهدوا الله من قبل لا
يولون
الادبار وكان عهد الله
مسؤولا قل لن ينفعكم الفرار ان فررتم من
الموت او القتل واذا لا تمتعون الا
قليلا قل من ذا الذي يعصمكم من الله ان
اراد بكم سوءا او اراد بكم رحمه
ولا يجدون لهم من دون الله وليا ولا
نصيرا قد يعلم الله المعوقين
منكم
والقائلين لاخوانهم هلم الينا ولا ياتون
الباس الا
قليلا اشحه عليكم فاذا جاء الخوف رايتهم
ين ينظرون اليك رايتهم ينظرون اليك تدور
اعينهم كالذي يغشى عليه من
الموت فاذا ذهب الخوف سلقوكم بالسنه حداد
اشحه على
الخير اولئك لم يؤمنوا فاحبط الله
اعمالهم وكان ذلك على الله
يسيرا يحسب بون الاحزاب لم يذهبوا وان
ياتي الاحزاب يودوا لو انهم بادون في
الاعراب يسالون عن
انبائكم ولو قاتلوا ولو قاتلوا ما ولو
كانوا فيكم ما قاتلوا الا
قليلا ولو كانوا فيكم ما قاتلوا الا قليلا
لقد كان في رسول الله اسوه حسنه لمن كان
يرجو الله واليوم الاخر وذكر الله
كثيرا ولما راى المؤمنون الاحزاب قالوا
هذا ما وعدنا الله ورسوله وصدق الله
ورسوله وما زادهم الا ايمانا
وتسليما من المؤمنين
رجال صدقوا ما عاهدوا الله
عليه فمنهم من قضى نحبه ومنهم من
ينتظر وما بدلوا
تبديلا ليجزي الصادقين
بصدقهم ليجزي الله الصادقين بصدقهم ويعذب
المنافقين ان شاء
الله كان غفورا
رحيما ورد الله الذين كفروا بغيظهم لم
ينالوا خيرا وكفى الله المؤمنين
القتال وكان الله
وكان الله عفو وكان الله عزيزا
قديرا وكان الله قويا عزيزا وانزل الذين
ظاهروهم من اهل الكتاب من صياصيهم وقذف في
قلوبهم
الرعب فريقا تقتلون وتاسرون
فريقا واورثكم ارضهم وديارهم واموالهم
وارضا لم
تطؤوها وكان الله على كل
شيء
قديرا الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شافع
استه just for those if youay with her
now of course you can have tonight as
well you just won pray with her tonight
so if you not coming back insall this
will be conclusion
‏back in the first
pleas we have space on side can you can
you move down this way can you
down we can fit one more person in the
front row
pleas have a second available please
don't start a
third there's no need for a
استوتاد وص
الخلم
استو الله سبحانه وتعالى امين الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يغفى
ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلن
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون
في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين بسم
الله قل هو الله
احد
الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن
له
كفوا احد
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم انا نشهد انك بينت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرد الصمد الذي لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن
عافيت وتولنا فيمن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك تقضي ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يذ واليت ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم تغفر
لنا وترحمنا لكونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو
فاعفوناه اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو ع
اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار ورقاب
والدينا وز
ذريتنا
وازواجنا
وارحامنا
وامهاتنا
وابائنا
واخواننا واصدقائنا من النار وادخلنا جنه
مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم لا تدع لنا في الليله المباركه
هذا الا ذنبا الا غفرته
ولا هما الا
فرجته ولا كربا الا
نفسته ولا ميتا الا
رحمته ولا ضالا الا
هديته ولا اولادا الا
اصلحته ولا حاجه من حوائج دنيا لك رضع
ولنا قضيتها ويسرتها لنا اللهم يا سامع
صوت ويا سابق الفوت ويا كافع العزاما لحما
بعد الموت اغفر لجميع الموتى
المسلمين الذين شهدوك
بالوحدانيه ونبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم واعف عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم
واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد ونقهم من
الذنوب والختايا كما ينقى الثوب الابيد من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما
احييتنا واجعله موارث منا واجعل ثارنا على
من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عا اعدائنا ولا
تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدست
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك وبحمدك اللهم عيد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب
المسلمين اللهم عيد المسجد الاقصى الى
رحاب المسلمين
اللهم عيد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب
المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل
الممات انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر والمسلمين اللهم انصر اخواننا
المستضعفين في كل مكان خاصه خصوص في الغزه
وفلسطين وفي السودان وفي الصين وفي برما
وفي كشمير
وفي
الهند اللهم انصرهم اللهم ايدهم بجنودك لا
يعلم جنودك الا انت اللهم اذل الشرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز اللهم اصلح احوالنا اللهم اصلح
احوالنا اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال
المسلمين اللهم اهدنا واهدي
المسلمين اللهم اللهم اسلح اولادنا واولاد
المسلمين اللهم تقبل منا صيامنا وصلاتنا
وقيامنا والقراننا وتجعل ولا تجعل حجه
علينا يا رب العالمين اللهم اجعله حجه لنا
ولا حجه علينا يا رب
العالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وكنا عذاب
القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شرفتنا محي
الممات وكنا شر فتنه المسيح
الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتوب علينا يا مولاناك يا تواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين